I know I know I've already unboxed the
air pause with the wireless charging
case but this is very very special I
ordered this almost I think like over a
month ago at this point I have been
traveling pretty much non-stop for the
past month so I've basically had these
air pods following me around the country
and trying to get them at first I worded
them to my parents house but then I
wasn't at my parents house to sign for
the package and then I decided that okay
well gonna be somewhere else so then I
had them redirected there and then I
wasn't gonna be at that location anymore
so finally I was like okay I'm just
gonna redirect them back to Los Angeles
and thankfully my sister was back here
and able to sign for them these guys
have traveled all around the country and
they have finally made it to me and just
to clarify this welded an Apple issue
this was a Justine issue because I kept
traveling and I kept missing the
delivery I had to keep redirecting it so
they did a really great job of routing
this thing all over the place
so let's open these up the thing that
I'm most excited about these is much
like the engraving on the Apple pencil
you couldn't put a lowercase letter
please you could so I was able to
actually get I just dean written on them
and this is gonna be good because my
sister and I both have air pods and we
tend to get them confused with each
other so now we won't have that issue
because my freaking name is on it so
backup jet off these are mine usually we
have to just open them next to each
other and see whose they are
oh it's so cute and small oh my god it
is so crazy it's a little have any of
you guys ever got your Apple products
engraved if you have let me know in the
comments below what did you guys get
engraved did you get your name's your
iPad or something engraved I would love
to know it is so small it's crazy and
like it is so small so if you're just
kind of glanced at it like you don't
really see it but if you really look
maybe get a magnifying glass whose air
pods are these are they're mine so at
this point it's probably been I guess
about a month with my ear pods feels
like I'm having an intervention here
with my air pods but they have been
really awesome
and since I have been traveling a lot
I've been using my wireless charging mat
a lot so I always have that set up by my
in hotel rooms or even when I'm home
with my parents house my mom has
wireless chargers and all of our
bedrooms which is from the cool a lot of
the things that she added fairly
recently I think in the past year or so
she was looking for little side tables
that doubled as a light and a wireless
charger so this is actually the one that
she ended up getting and I really love
it so mom really great job on the light
purchases you can also change the color
temperature in this light so you could
change it from warm to cool and you can
dim it and of course it has the built-in
wireless charger so that's really nice
whenever I'm home I can just throw my
phone down and now I can throw my air
pods on to charge I feel like my
previous version of the air posit didn't
have the wireless charging case I would
always find them dead so I have to
charge them really quickly using some
sort of portable charger what a month
ago but now I feel like when I get home
I just kind of add this as my routine of
throwing this other wireless charger let
those charged and then after I'm done
with my phone before I go to bed I just
swap my phone on and then the air fives
are usually pretty charged for the next
day so one of the things that I did
notice is a big difference is how
quickly these did pair to different
devices the previous version without the
wireless charging case did take a little
bit longer to connect and we're not
talking like it's significantly longer
but if it's something that you do every
day day in day out switching from your
iPhone to your Mac to your iMac or
something like that
you got really accustomed to how quickly
something happened so with these it does
happen a little bit quicker so I'm not
really sure how much time I've saved
myself in total from trying to swap
between air pods and my back but it is
faster so all-in-all that's a good thing
I've also been joined all the air pods
memes I just I don't know it's really
really funny to me I think it was a few
months ago they were like an air pods
use your meetup or something a bunch of
the guys are tweeting me that you were
going fortunately it wasn't in towns I
wasn't able to go because I thought that
would actually be kind of funny
ear pods meet up a lot it's almost the
dumbest thing that I've ever heard and
it's also absolutely genius and I'm
still upset that I couldn't make it so
really I just wanted to unbox this
because this has had such a long journey
to get to me but I almost thought that
they were ready to get shipped back to
Apple and then I would never see them
again and then ever just get my money
reimbursed but I really wanted these I'm
very glad that they finally made their
way to my house I'm also glad that I
made my way back to my house honestly
I'm so exhausted from traveling it is
just something that really takes a toll
on your body I've had a good time
visiting family and friends and I went
to the YouTube creator summit that was
in New York this past week and that was
so much fun because I got to see a lot
of old youtuber friends and I met a lot
of new youtuber friends it's really cool
just to see how much this community has
grown and how many people are actually
creating on this platform it's also
really cool to hear from YouTube talking
about some of the new features of course
there's a lot of drama that's happening
on YouTube all the time so it is really
great to hear from YouTube directly
speaking to us answering our questions
and sometimes we get some answers I
guess that brings this Airport video to
a close I mean I don't really know what
else I can do that I haven't done
already I mean they're airports they
have wireless charging case you already
saw me unbox and talk about these the
first time around so of course you don't
really have anything else to say other
than I think the engraving is really
cool I like it I'm excited about it and
if I leave these anywhere I guess at
least somebody will know who to return
them to let me know in the comments
below if there's any other videos you'd
like to see me make and also be sure to
hit subscribe if you haven't hit the
bell already do so hit the Bell and
tweet me a screenshot of you guys
hitting the Bell because if that will
allow you to get notifications so you
guys know when I post new videos you
don't want to miss this quality content
because honestly where else are you
gonna get this act no where no where
[Music]